this exclusive Fox video of Pasquale
parada the ousted head of scott pruett
security detail meeting today with
investigators from the House Oversight
Committee shows questions about the cost
of the epa chiefs security arrangements
are accelerating as Pruitt also faces
new scrutiny about why a lobbyist and
friend set up a one hundred thousand
dollar trip to Morocco in December the
Washington Post revealing that last
month the lobbyists inked a $40,000 a
month contract with the Moroccan
government raising questions about
whether Pruitt ran afoul of federal laws
banning officials from using government
resources to help friends is draining
the swamp renting an apartment from the
wife of a Washington lobbyist I don't
think that that's even remotely fair to
ask that question in an interview with
Fox last month focused in part on
Pruitt's arrangements with other
lobbyists the epa chief defended the
trip to Morocco that included a stop in
Paris eight staffers and
around-the-clock security sandwich
students but the the two trips and that
I took were all an advancement of air
quality issues environmental issues
except last week at a house hearing
Pruitt was pressed on why he has also
claimed part of the trip was spent
promoting us liquefied natural gas
imports when that is the job of the
Department of Energy through it shifted
to say he was negotiating the
environmental section of a free trade
agreement and changed the story he had
initially told Fox about not knowing
there were large pay raises for two
other friends I'm not afraid to admit
that there's been a learning process
another Pruett friend who handled some
of his personal banking in Oklahoma
Albert Kelly was ousted this week from a
top EPA post Pruitt had defended hiring
Kelly even though the FDIC banned him
for life I don't know the terms of that
agreement I'm told after Fox posted that
interview the White House started asking
more questions about prudes banker so
while the president has kept him on
board and supports his cutting of
regulations they're keeping a close eye
on where these investigations Cobra I
mean that's really what matters whether
the president sees him as somebody who
has the president support there are
others in the White House who seem to be
frustrated with one issue after another
but the president's behind him he's
still in the job